Sì.
Quindi andando avanti, i bit e i qubit
saranno il paradiso computazionale fondamentale
con cui potremo affrontare
problemi complessi nel mondo,
quindi cerchiamo di capire la differenza tra loro
e da dove nasce la potenza dei qubit.
Se guardiamo il lato sinistro,
è un modo per descrivere — e useremo questi diagrammi
in tutta la presentazione per
mostrare la potenza — vediamo un cerchio
e due punti: quando il punto si trova al polo nord
è uno zero, quando è al polo sud è un uno.
Questo è un bit classico a due stati. Ora un qubit è la
unità di informazione nel mondo quantistico
e qui inizia il bello con il disegno:
la sfera è sia zero che uno,
e possiamo averli in questo stato di sovrapposizione.
Abbiamo un trucco speciale a nostra disposizione:
non solo possiamo posizionarli sulla sfera,
ma immagina che ognuno di questi
sia come una piccola luna
nella sfera, e possiamo ruotare la luna.
Quindi qui vedi che
la sfera in basso è stata ruotata leggermente,
ed è per questo che vedi un po' di blu
e rosa — e potremmo ruotarla completamente.
Qui c'è una rotazione di centottanta gradi.
Abbiamo quindi questa nozione di fase che il mondo quantistico ci offre:
tre superpoteri che si manifestano nei qubit.
Sono i poteri della sovrapposizione,
il potere dell'interferenza
e il potere dell'entanglement.
Quindi esaminiamoli: il principio di sovrapposizione è in realtà
abbastanza semplice da capire.
Quindi partendo dal lato sinistro:
siamo al polo nord zero o al polo sud uno,
e se sommiamo questi due stati
otteniamo un qubit in sovrapposizione che ha sia
zero che uno simultaneamente — polo nord
e polo sud. Il diagramma a destra è lo stesso,
ma ora faremo un piccolo trucco:
applicheremo un gate, un quantum gate.
Quello che abbiamo fatto qui, ricorda,
è che possiamo cambiare — possiamo
ruotare queste piccole lune, giusto?
Quindi l'abbiamo ruotata di cento
e ottanta gradi, e ora abbiamo un uno.
Quindi ora quando facciamo la somma di zero più uno, otteniamo
uno stato di sovrapposizione,
ma nota che è diverso:
quello a sinistra è sempre
uno zero e un uno, ma ora con uno stato ruotato
per il qubit uno. Questo sarà molto potente
per sfruttare una seconda cosa davvero interessante, che è
il principio di interferenza.
Questa non è un'operazione che possiamo eseguire nel mondo classico
dei bit. Quindi in questo esempio abbiamo
uno zero e un uno a sinistra, più
questo nuovo stato che abbiamo creato,
che è anch'esso zero e un uno,
ma con questa luna ruotata. Quando facciamo questo ora,
possiamo far interferire questi due stati
e nota che è successa una cosa molto interessante:
abbiamo cancellato lo stato uno
e siamo rimasti con lo stato zero.
L'abbiamo fatto perché abbiamo fatto interferire gli stati.
La prossima opportunità che abbiamo adesso è:
quanti stati possiamo creare?
La cosa bella nel mondo quantistico è che possiamo creare un numero esponenziale
di stati. Quindi guardiamo un sistema che ha
cinque qubit. In questo caso stiamo raffigurando questi qubit
come qubit indipendenti — li vedi a sinistra:
zeri e uni che vengono moltiplicati. Ne abbiamo cinque,
quindi il numero di stati che possiamo creare
nel computer quantistico raffigurato sulla sfera a destra
è due alla potenza
del numero di qubit che abbiamo — in questo caso cinque.
Quindi due alla quinta è trentadue stati.
Stiamo vedendo trentadue di quelle piccole lune.
Nota che in questo caso non abbiamo incorporato
nessuna fase — sono tutte rosa. L'aspetto potente di
usare questa proprietà chiamata entanglement nel mondo quantistico
è che possiamo ora creare stati
come quello raffigurato a destra,
dove abbiamo queste combinazioni di rosa
e blu, dove quello stato non può essere descritto
come il prodotto indipendente
di questi cinque qubit. In questo caso,
dato che abbiamo trentadue stati,
quello che questo ci dice è qualcosa di davvero profondo.